tout le monde n'est pas prêt à avouer
qu'il a voté pour jaillir bolsonaro au
premier tour de l'élection
mais Alberto lui ne s'en cache pas et au
plus fine
il aurait préféré bolsonaro gagne au
premier tour Alberto est chauffeur d'un
grand hôtel de Rio l'auto lui appartient
déjà en 2018 il a voté bolsona 4 ans
plus tard il est satisfait il se dit de
droite
totalement de droite mais pas fanatique
il ne critique ni la gestion de la covid
par son président ni celle de l'Amazonie
par exemple faites vols
il a réalisé de grands projets et
combattu la corruption et la
déforestation en Amazonie
l'élection a montré que le Brésil est
dans le fond plus conservateur compensé
comme Alberto les 43% des lecteurs qui
ont appuyé jaillir bolsonaro presque la
moitié ne sont évidemment pas d'extrême
droite mais ils appuient une politique
d'extrême droite qui selon l'ONG
opensity vice carrément à détruire la
démocratie brésilienne je crois qu'il y
a un mélange de frustration avec la
classe politique rationnelle qui
continue à bolsonaro il a réussi un peu
comme 30 à être
le stable je me contre les stable
de front aux institutions le Congrès la
Cour suprême le système électoral une
partie de la société civile la presse il
est critiqué aussi pour avoir facilité
l'accès aux armes à feu mais ça l'a
rendu populaire chez des gens comme
Alberto
[Applaudissements]
nous vivons dans un pays violent dit-il
léger moi-même été agressé
pistolet sur la tempe il aurait une arme
si le permis n'était pas encore aussi
cher et je crois que cette polarisation
encore plus forte entre bolsonaro et
Lola à l'élection de 2018 Pedro abromova
et nous avait dit que bolsonaro était
dangereux il est encore plus dangereux
exactement parce que
ses collègues Forr ainsi dire
autoritaires
urban et ben
ortegger pendant plusieurs contextes
différents ils ont
quand on va le premier mandat
c'était envoyé encore les institutions
démocratiques fonctionnent c'est au
second mandat que la Hongrie la Turquie
et le Nicaragua entre autres ont pris le
virage autoritaire et je crois que c'est
le trajectoire
en 30 octobre
si on va rétablir le procès démocratique
au Brésil les institutions brésiliennes
pourraient-elles résister à un deuxième
mandat de bolsonarisme en tout cas au
deuxième tour le 30 octobre j'arrière
Bolson arrow aura une forte panthe à
remonter s'il ne veut pas devenir le
premier président du Brésil moderne a
raté sa réélection et dans ce cas comme
aux Etats-Unis le Trump tropical
acceptera-t-il la défaite rien n'est
garanti Jean-Michel Leprince a du Canada
riojaneiro